[Music]
this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon everyone
well no better way to start an afternoon
game Drive then with the little prince
who's posing ever so beautifully he must
have known that it's time to shine
because he has been lying in long grass
pretty much the entire day close to
where we left him this morning and all
of a sudden he is just working I've been
appeared out of the long grass in the
last two minutes so he's kind of
spoiling us a little bit imposing ever
so beautifully my name is Justin on
camera I've got Craig this afternoon and
it is a very warm welcome to Juma and
South Africa and we'll play a warm
welcome from husana to remember we are
coming to you live so we would love to
hear any questions that you have about
not only husana but any other things in
the wilderness and you can just send
your questions through to hashtag safari
live on twitter or at FC on the YouTube
chat now I have giggled and laughed at
Hasan I've been with him since about
2:00 o'clock so in the last sort of two
hours in sitting around with Hasan I
just kind of seen what he gets up to and
sort of patiently watching him and I've
giggled at his hunting this afternoon
because he has paid zero zero zero zero
zero attention to any antelope like an
Impala but as soon as the biggest male
water bike you've ever seen arrives now
he wants to hunt that so it doesn't
matter that they are antelope that I
within his sort of hunting range he's
decided that big male waterbuck are part
and parcel of what he's going to be
hunting for the day which is quite
ridiculous because a big bear water
bucket really is not on the menu for
Sahn it's a bit too big and powerful for
him but never this one can dream and one
can try you never know actually I
suppose it is possible that he might
bring one down but I highly doubt it I
think he'd have a tough time to bring
that down and when you serve I certainly
wouldn't be able to keep it that's for
sure so we'll see how he goes for the
afternoon he is looking like he's
working up quite a bit now unfortunately
all the impalas have left but what I
will say is that if we start to see
impalas coming down which should happen
now that it's late afternoon coming
we're gonna give him quite a lot of
space
we're not gonna park anywhere near him
because what I did noticed during the
course of today is anywhere where the
car parks these animals will alarm call
edit even if you know we're near him
I'll at one point parked quite far from
him where I knew I could see him if he
moved but wasn't anywhere close to him
and every single Impala was just staring
at me and shouting so if impalas do come
along this way we are going to make a
concerted effort to give him quite a lot
of room and try and form from quite far
away in order to give him the best
possible chance to hunt as well as we're
so just to not be in the way and ruin
anything that could go on so that's the
idea for the afternoon hopefully a
little star will stick around for the
day
Chris unfortunate that question is a
little bit like how long as a ball of
string it depends really on so many
factors as to how long it will take for
them to pounce when they are stalking a
a prey source obviously these guys
mostly will try and get as close as
possible in in ambush out and grab
whatever it is and sometimes that can be
anywhere from five minutes to two hours
three hours it just depends you know
it's always different in its waste it
depends on the movement of other animals
the cover that they've got and how they
kind of position themselves but I always
find with these guys is that they'll
wait until the last possible second
before they pound so they hope they try
and let that animal come as close as
possible before they decide to do
anything
isn't he cute though same kind of
peering over the bushes
Isana cat there's no animals for you to
hunt just yet what was interesting
though is that there was also alarm
calls on both sides of the dam so
there's alarm calls far to the north
towards Tumblety dam and also some alarm
calls in the Milwaukee system so there
are obviously other things moving around
I wonder if we're not gonna see some of
those felines moving this where I say
freelancers imagine it would be some
sort of cat that was moving in those
areas that were you going to set boy if
you decided that's your spot for the off
scene did you just stand on your own
tail
apparently one needs to pin one's tail
because it gets unruly when lying down
and I don't know if you noticed that but
he just stood on his own tail as he was
lying down as if to say tail you are not
going anywhere you will behave yourself
and you'll sit right here with me you're
not allowed to go off on your own little
mission ok he kind of just moved himself
and then sets on down and putting his
tail so that he was perfectly
comfortable and I don't think he's gonna
sit here for long and I think he'll be
moving just now anything's gonna be out
in the open for too long
Michelle you say he is just too handsome
he is very pretty isn't he's at that
stage of a male if it's life we're not
too many scars is kind of as
good-looking as he's ever going to be
and we've seen that with tumblr tumblr
was looking very handsome and nice but a
little bit of a broken yeah
and so Masana will slowly start to show
the scars of male lipid hood head he's
got one on his nose and those will get
more and more as life goes on good now
we're gonna sit with hasana for the
afternoon he's sure to be entertained
already so far it's been good and
meantime let's send you across a to
Lauren says she can say good afternoon
hi Lauren says hi everyone and good
afternoon I have already said my name
but on camera today I have Senzo who is
feeling much better
aren't you since he gave me the thumbs
up he's feeling better he's been a
trooper and he's out here with us all on
board the vehicle today to see what we
can find
now saying so is my lucky charm I always
have amazing sightings with him and of
course we found husana yesterday it was
just incredible and I did watch back the
moment that it happens and I do appear
to make many amusing facial expressions
and many of his screams surely that
thank you for that I love them all I was
just so shocked my mind could not
compute how husana is there but he's
also in one deluzy so my brain was
thinking well that can't be hosanna but
him who I was gonna be and I just got
myself very very confused of course and
Tristan is correct he's looking so
handsome we got some great views of him
yesterday really really perfect
positioning and he is a handsome boy I
talk about him a lot when I go home and
I think some people think I have a
boyfriend called hasana
they must just assume that it's the main
man in my life which is not the case he
obviously is a cat but I do talk about
him a lot and I actually even showed my
mother a photo of Basara
on my phone because I was proud it was a
really nice cool my mom said oh it's a
sauna for those of you don't know who
bucerias she's a female cheetah not a
male leopard yes my mother has just got
so much to learn anyway we're driving
very very slowly in case any of you
noticed because apparently there was
lots of a la Impala alarm calling from
this area haven't seen any tracks
other than alleys there's a lot of le
tracks I have a funny feeling we're
gonna bump into a breeding here at some
point but no cats or any other sort of
tracks so this is hosannas sort of not
hasana
Jenga Ana's favorite area at the minute
so I'm not actively searching for him
but I am scattering the area to see
exactly who was alarm calling and why
alarm calling when Impala go crazy like
that you really have to pay attention
it's exactly what happened to me
yesterday
[Music]
Karen's askin has Hosanna ran into ten
gana lately now the last we have seen
and you know you never know what
actually happens at night time here I
think it was last week cuz that right
sends yeah I lose track of time here I
couldn't even tell you what day the week
it is
oh it's Sunday cuz it's Father's Day so
happy Father's Day to all the fathers
out there jet fathers adopted fathers
uncles everybody yes I knew two cents he
has gorgeous little twins so happy
Father's Day so I do know it's Sunday
but my point is I think it was about a
week ago that James had an interaction
between Hosanna and sing Ghana and it's
something we discuss a lot at camp
because it is so pivotal pivotal in
hosannas future or his immediate present
I guess and sing Ghana yeah he smiles he
JC's but it's not as nowhere near as
aggressive as it would be of the likes
of Foucault Murray and huka Murray
is believed to be the reason that
Hosanna is back with us apparently they
had a bit of an interaction a bit of a
fight and Hosanna ran all the way back
home bless so Tinga knows reaction is
really not that fierce now why there's
so much speculation obviously he does
know it's his son he'll be well aware
that that's his son but he's obviously a
dominant territorial male and his sons
getting bigger and stronger and stealing
carcasses and eating carcasses with in
his father's territory so yes they have
bumps in but the last thing that we are
aware was with James and I think it was
possibly with you all last week we
haven't seen the two of them interact
since then but who knows what goes on
when the cameras are not on them I just
wonder if 10 Ghana will remain like this
will remain completely tolerant and tell
them to go away but not overly
aggressive how long will that last
I'm really not sure alrighty of course
it's not just tristin husana and
I Steve as out this afternoon as well so
let's go across and say hi
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
my vehicle my name is indeed Steve
joined by Darby Seto
on camera in a very warm and merry
Father's Day to all of you I know it's
not Father's Day all over the world but
in South Africa the most certainly is
well this morning I was out on tracking
tip and managed to find the tandy which
was very very cool found some steaming
dress and then we found some more female
tracks and we weren't able to find who
it was but we're given the report later
on and Trish notes has tasks to boot our
our Tandy was drooling and really
salivating and then subbu he was found
towards the end of Drive there are twin
dance are we gonna go there and see why
attendee or exactly what's been going on
and Tandy was getting a little bit
annoyed I suppose with Shibuya
encroaching in on a territory but I
found tracks of another leopard very
close to where left sandy last night so
there's a very good chance they might
have had an altercation and then Tristan
obviously tracks and found husana right
where he is now but I found his tracks
all the way in the east with another
male and they came all the track them
all the way back to where he is so he
did an enormous loop last night probably
found the tracks of his dad followed him
for a little bit and then this is where
Tristan left in Ghana last night so was
the end of our rehearsal he went in that
direction and then the tracks went all
the way north and west to pull the sock
with another male and there was
something going on with everybody
tracking this morning but no one was
able to find those two so anyway we're
gonna go see if we can follow up on
Sabri and if we can't we gonna see if we
can find Tanya in the meantime mr. Lord
who's got a beautiful beautiful bit
well we did have a word and it flew away
but I think there we go well done sense
you are an absolute hero Oh honestly
okay it's up ahead shall we move signs
or to the end you know let's not move
okay it is of course a Kingfisher a
brown hooded Kingfisher I think who we
had perfectly poised in position there
but immediately as you saw it flew off
and now we don't quite have the best
view of it but we still do have a view
of it should we try and get closer and
crane are you guys ready for this you
know what the birds are like I
absolutely I think out of all the birds
groups kingfishers have to be my
favorite stay okay
Oh can you work with that he said an
amazing job with this because it's not
easy trying to follow Birds sometimes I
feel like they just know that you want
to get the camera and they just will not
allow any sort of sighting of them there
we go it's not perfect but you can
definitely see even sort of glaring in
the Sun that silhouetted look you can
actually see immediately that it as a
Kingfisher and the brown hooded
Kingfisher is actually part of the house
Ian's group of kingfishers and you can
sort of tell that immediate with the
fact that it does have blue on the wings
and it's one of the smaller kingfishers
not the smallest but it's one of the
smaller ones and believe it or not the
female is actually larger than the male
the sexes are very similar very
difficult to discriminate between the
two but the females are Oh Megan said
that's our 198 bird I hope I got the
number right there
Oh Megan I'm so happy for you I also
have a bird list as well I keep it on my
phone every time I see a new species I
write it down so I'm very happy
you saw that and I got it right it was a
hundred in India very very happy for you
so yes it's impossible for me to tell
right now if it is male or female
but if you saw them together the female
would be bigger than the meal you can
see that big beak there because it feeds
on insects so and he's a big beak to
stab them and eat them
so I'm glad we managed to get a view of
it for you it took a lot of effort but
for now we're gonna send you back to
Tristan and his spotted cat
hopefully that brown hoodie kingfisher
makes an appearance but for now
Kasana as well he's posing there was
beautifully as you could ever imagine to
start anything in the sunshine he was
trying to chase the dye care that
unfortunately ran away from him
we tried to move just a little bit and
that's the problem with dye kisses
dijkers as soon as they pick up any sort
of movement or of a car they move away
which is unfortunate so it's not ideal
for us
that's that happened but it was so has
been shot at at by about 40 other
impalas and that were around and they
behind him to the right there you can
see them there so they were shouting at
him and making quite a lot of noise and
that's why he's just standing out in the
open not really sure where he's going to
go but he needs to position himself
somewhere where it's quite dense and
quite thick and then wait and eventually
we're gonna find a lot of animals are
gonna come pasture and to drink are
saying it earlier that it's the time of
the day when they do drink and so if he
can get himself into a nice thicket then
it's gonna be much better
then what precautions to be taken our
safety with predators
really that many I suppose the just give
them space as much as possible and try
not to make too much movement or sort of
move around them too fast or anything
like that and then generally you're
alright you generally don't have to
worry too much if that's the case I find
most predators I actually quite sort of
calm around vehicles in this area that's
not to say you know the areas that it
would be the same but here where we are
it seems that most of our cats don't
mind the cars around us and as long as
you're not driving over their tails or
into them or chasing them off their food
you're typically going to be quite
alright when it comes to kind of viewing
them so see look now he's gonna go into
his little thicket and is hopefully
going to find a place where he can sit
that the impalas won't see him and what
we're gonna do is we're gonna park quite
far now unfortunately there's going to
be other vehicles that are gonna come
which is means that we knock on really
dictates it's how close they Park but
we're gonna try and park a little bit
differently to everybody else so we're
gonna go quite far Park up the hill here
and to try and see if maybe just maybe
these impalas will come walking along
the road like they often do in the hope
that they'll walk towards where he is
we're just gonna stop yeah
DNA should he decide to stalk so he's in
that Bush over there we're not going to
have a great visual of hasanah which is
fine I prefer him to be able to hunt
then fast to worry about which position
he's in and you know being close to him
to be able to see him I think if we
search out and in parlors do you decide
to move well then we're going to be in
prime position to see any sort of hunt
that does take place so it's a good
place to check in a good place to sit I
might move actually a little bit more
than what we have right now just because
I'd find that the proximity to the bush
limping parlor stone comes through so
Judy used nine years old Judy how much
does Hasani eats every single day Oh
difficult to say Julie because he
doesn't eat every single day so what he
requires is he requires large meals at
times where he can then feed and be able
to kind of make his tummy as full as
possible and in some days he'll go to
three four five six seven days without
eating but in terms of actually probably
surviving I'd say probably I don't know
maybe seven kilograms of no not even
five kilograms of meat today would be
probably very good for him
but most times he won't even eat
anywhere close to that in a day you
won't have anything at all but what
happens is he'll kill something like an
Impala and that Impala will last him
three four days and he'll eat so much to
the point where it's not survival it's
just kind of making his tummy fuller
than full he'll make his tummy as big as
possible and then that will kind of keep
him going through the days where he's
not able to eat unfortunately I didn't
think my plan is going to work too well
because the cars are gonna come from
that side which means the Impala is
going to take a long time to come
through now they're gonna unfortunately
wait for everybody to settle so they'll
have to be patient and just wait for
everything they'll eventually come
though because water is what's in
there's no other words he knew it close
by so he just needs to sit for quite a
while and wait and that's why these guys
are gonna go around are they gonna pop
behind us somewhere but they can whistle
awesome space good anyway while we
search earn wait for her so let's see if
he's gonna get anything to eat sin to
meantime let's enjoy cross to Steve
who's checking water halls of his own
well thank you Tristan you are at one
watering hole we are at another we left
Tandy
right down on the bottom of this dam
wall yesterday evening and this is where
Sabri was found this morning so it's
gonna scratch around here and see if
maybe we can be lucky with her myself
and sins or who was it was you me the
other day a founder just up here I
wasn't very far at all here little day
could kill so to be nice if we could
find him she's a very pretty young lady
I'm Ellie
Tristan's girlfriend reckons she is the
prettiest leopard around obviously that
caused all sorts of discussions at the
dinner table
I think Columba is a gorgeous gorgeous
leopard but did I think all female if
it's a beautiful okay so sorry about
that
game drive I do have a issue with my
game driver idiot meaning it has to be
open or there's a green pigeon there
Darby always a god I just flown off
green pigeon was busy drinking water the
effort you got a nice one African green
pigeon any call that they do okay so
we're gonna scratch around here we'll
see who and if we can find and while we
do that I mean who are the three female
lipids are on the mat with the Columba
Tandy and sub we how about a little pole
for all of you viewers at home on little
Twitter Paul who do you think is the
most beautiful between the three we've
got Java as well this is gonna get very
awkward isn't a day it's gonna get
awkward faith Kent can we do have poll
the four and we do for toke a child her
in there because she's around she's also
very pretty it's throw four in there if
there's doable I don't know how these
things work okay Paul the form could
could Java Tandy Columba and subbu II
sent to your votes right now let's see
exactly who you in the viewers
think is the prettiest prettiest of them
all at the moment and then we'll ask I
think as well
Oh Ellen that's a very question we're
not expecting so it's going to be some
very hard times here very very did we
literally rain we might have a very out
of season rain as well but I've got a
feeling things are gonna be quite dire
here this year gonna be quite dire last
year was far more water than this and
they were Hugh there was huge die-off of
Buffalo in the Kruger Park and the year
before so very hard to say really
but hopefully something turns around but
unfortunate that's what happens you get
these dry and wet periods and clout the
week they remove there we go she was
like honey yeah
so we wished she was like that's a very
good start you got a derby okay so she
was lying here let me just have a little
scan before I jump out of the car and
this is a typical sort of body posture
of a cat that has been lying down let's
double check it is a cat and not a hyena
was lying here you can see that there
was a foot in there this actually looks
like a hyena was lying here there's
another foot there the bottom comes over
here and more of the body all the way
over here with front legs the bottom
around here with two feet in the back
and then the front of the body even the
head was on the ground it actually has
moved a little bit in the ground obvious
or quite a big hyena should give it a
smell Conrad our technician he said he
got woken up the other night with a
hyena outside his window that worked him
cause of the smell can you imagine
something walks past your window
probably close window
don't really smell anything
see if there's any hairs in here any
hairs hello no hair's lovely track there
but this was a hyena I didn't drive on
this piece this morning but ya hyenas
moved off over here but there is there
is a leopard track so it's possible that
this hyena was following her they like
to do that they like to sort of find the
leopards in it follow them because you
know leopards are very good at providing
food for these hyena and I've got a very
strong feeling me if we put a little bit
of effort in and we keep our ears open
they're probably going to hear or see
something in this area and if not we're
gonna get put in some effort to find her
nemesis at the moment which is Tandy and
obviously watering sources leopards and
lions and hyenas obviously their
territory sort of overlap water points
and so this twin dams would be a highly
contested sort of area indeed but how
far into Tandy's territory will she come
very hard to say okay well while we try
and make head or tail of where these
tracks go let's go of she's had luck in
the area of king Ghana
we have just arrived
damn we only have one people today who
are you and where's your buddy just is
this okay for you sense o Sens oh he
doesn't want to fit the hip bones no
he's joking there we go we have a very
lazy hippo and the dam to me still looks
like the shape of a fish I don't know if
it does to other people but every time I
come here I think that is a fish so this
is either Scuba Steve or snorkel Sarah
who knows it's not so easy to identify
your hippos and I can see from here one
two three four Birds on the back saying
so give us a better view there yes four
little Pickers picking away and cannot
be pleasant and I don't think that dam
looks very pleasant at all either
Pickers now funny enough we came here
one night and I think it was the night
that we actually had the Avoca meal here
so we were about to talk about the
hippos and of course he of alchemy of
just came and all attention got
diversity but when you look at the hippo
and FLIR sometimes when we got to check
what dam we put the FLIR camera on the
thermal camera but you're not is that
hippos are quite far away but when you
come here and you put this hippo under
the thermal camera you're actually able
to see lots of yellow white dots across
the body and they're quite large and we
actually had a discussion saying what is
that and from what we can see or what we
can believe hello looks rather grumpy I
think so looks like little wounds almost
and could be now this is just me
speculate and I don't have any proof of
this but it could be where the oxpecker
is how
coold something out of the body so it's
a small little wood nothing deep nothing
dangerous to the animal but that area
will obviously be hot cause it's healing
so though you know your body's fighting
infection or trying to heal uh cuts it
can always feel warmer than other parts
of your body so I think when you look at
this hippo in the FLIR and all these
white dots across the body are actually
from the oxpeckers and they're small
tiny little wounds and it's utterly
fascinating we're not able to show you
this right at the minute of course we're
not got a FLIR camera with us but when
we do we bow show you and it was it was
so interesting to look at a lot of
animals get really uncomfortable with
the oxpeckers it can't be pleasant
having something on you that's pulling
things out of you it can you know I'm
sure if the chick or the parasite or
whatever it is is lodged in our
uncomfortable place it can't feel too
pleasant and you can actually see this
when you watch the animals they try and
shake the birds off and of course
there's a big debate in science we do
mention this regularly you are sort of
you know in in school or even at
university it's a mutual relationship
between the animal and the oxpeckers but
the question really is now is it is it
really neutral or is it more parasitic
and there's debates for both both sides
here so is the oxpecker helping or
actually making wounds worse
mitch is asking a question and I think
we could ask the Lord about the hippos
leaving the dam when it gets to work to
dry sorry and yes I'll have to they are
truly amphibious animals and they really
require the water they cannot survive
without keeping their skin moist and wet
so right now I don't even know if that
water looks looks very sludgy that's the
word I would use to describe it sludge
so it's very stagnant it's not clean
water at all a lot of the other water
holes around here and much better
condition and of course it's because of
the hippos themselves defecating in the
water pumping and all that extra
nutrients it makes the water become
really unclean filled with bacteria
extra nutrients and then your algae
comes which is why the dam looks so
green sometimes so the hippos will leave
I don't know where I mean it looks like
there's quite a fair bit of water there
the hippo still looks quite comfortable
there but yes definitely at some point
the hippo will up and leave when the
dress becomes completely dry I don't
know when that will be when that's gonna
happen all depends on the sort of
environmental conditions and the weather
but when it does the hippos all leave
hmm Nancy's asking good oxpecker
oxpeckers clean out human wounds as well
now that's a tricky question because
what the oxpeckers are doing here is not
cleaning not cleaning the animal they
are literally plucking things out of the
animal which is slightly different so
they're plucking off
parasites any sort of you know arthropod
egg animal that's in there
the oxpeckers are plucking them out
which obviously is a great source of
food for them humans I guess I'm just
thinking us over in my brain I guess if
we had Tex which humans do get text and
oxpecker probably could pluck it out for
us absolutely but not necessarily clean
if that makes sense now I don't believe
an ox peckerwoods ever land or not human
and start to plug all the ticks off of
us but in terms of possible is it
possible then yes I guess it is I
actually had to remove ticks off my dog
when I was at home and it was not
pleasant but they're very visible you
know you can see them and there's a
special method of removing them of
course so yeah oxpeckers could
potentially do it but I don't believe
the ever woodsman it definitely wouldn't
clean the wound so going back to that
debate there's a lot of literature and
science right now calling them little
vampires because they're sort of sucking
all the blood and the parasites off
animals but they're leaving behind
wounds and they're actually said to meet
the wounds worse antique blood from the
fresh wound which does not help the
animal at all so they dig in at the
wounds and make it much much worse which
side of the fence you're on is up to you
there's there's a big debate I don't
think it's proven either way at the
minute but it's a really really
interesting topic and of course I was
just reference you're looking at the
hippo and FLIR and you can see all these
little wounds all over the body so I'm
guessing they come from the oxpeckers
but that does highlight that maybe the
orcs papers are detrimental to the
animal not quite sure how they will
prove that but it's definitely a hot
topic right now
now when I come to beautiful silk I like
to just stay a few minutes to see if
anything appears or anything comes out
we have obviously had some awesome honey
badger sightings here so it's always
good just to work wait a few minutes and
see what happens
so that's exactly what we're gonna do
but why are we do that they're gonna
send you back to my favorite handsome
boy not Tristan I'm talking about Hasan
oh yes well that would be a bit awkward
um I think Hasan is very much
everybody's favorite at the moment
unfortunately you don't have a view of
him at all we were trying to be patient
and wait for these impalas to move but
for now they're just sitting there and
kind of waiting and milling about much
like we are and you can see they're
quite alert in town the wind blows or
any sort of movement you'll find these
impalas actually pop their heads up and
they look around and obviously look in
our direction too impalas are incredibly
intelligent animals and they've people
don't give them credit for it but they
know very well that lots of cars mean
potential danger or so I'm pretty sure
this is the same a herd of Impala that's
already drank here today and they
already know that there's a liquid
around and if they need to be careful
and so that's why they just kind of
making sure that they're watching and
checking what's going on I think
eventually what we're gonna see is them
starting to come towards this area and
coming to drink a little bit late if the
cars will move on then you'll find that
you're you know they'll start to come
down but until then it's just gonna be a
patience game most of the impalas that
we've seen here are for the females
there'll be the odd male that will be
mixed in amongst them and the right
season is gonna start to die down quite
a bit now what we're gonna see is that
these guys most of these females should
already have been mated with and should
be theoretically pregnant those that are
gonna fall pregnant
you do get a later rut which does
sometimes take place in a sort of May
June but I think we're getting past that
point now it should be almost at the
time where is there he's walking now
Craig he's come right out into the open
so he's not even hiding these impalas
we'll be able to see him very very
clearly because of how kind of Arts in
the open he actually is at the moment
he's just sitting behind the back of a
vehicle watching what he's watching is
there something else coming from behind
us doesn't reflect it so Matt the reason
why the impalas are not running away
even though they know he's here is
because it's quite simple as that from
where they are um they can see him and
so there's no point in him moving and
and trying to run away and then not
knowing where that lipid goes then he
can stalk them again from where they are
they can watch him see him and make sure
that they are keeping an eye on where he
is and make sure that he is kind of in
their field of view and they don't have
to worry too much about being hunted so
often you'll see predator prey animals
who actually follow a predator sometimes
keeping eyes on them making sure that
they are not in any way disturbing will
make sure that that's that predator is
not getting anywhere away from them and
being able to hide again to hunt them so
it's just obviously an interesting way
that he does think well that they do
things the problem is is I don't know
what he's watching because I can't see
anything at this stage that he could
potentially be stalking he's definitely
following something and just have no
idea what it is the thing is is the more
he moves the more the impalas look the
more they might see him and the less
chance he's got of being successful now
the monkeys are alarm calling it to me
is having a tough time here
unfortunately he needs to stay hidden if
he is to to be successful wait for the
cover of darkness
but until then he's gonna have a tricky
tricky time pass him through the bushes
they're still watching these impalas but
I think the more space we give him the
better it's going to be for Salah but
look at how he's creeping and they're
cool
we're just gonna stay exactly where we
are we're not gonna move at all and
hopefully eventually he's gonna start
stalking towards this area all the
composites to start moving and hills to
be able to stalk them from where he's
lying but I feel sorry for him in some
respects because he tries to move in the
monkey shots at him it's like there's
aerial watch this ground watch it's
tough to be a to be a predator sometimes
so he's gonna have to be very very very
lucky to get this right unfortunately
with the the way things work in the way
you know animals are sensitive to what's
around them you're gonna find that's
gonna be very tricky for him to hunt us
herd this herd will be on extra alert
but you can see eyes patterning works
and those kind of shaded areas at Rick's
very well to kind of camouflage himself
and stay hidden good we gonna stay with
hasanah will remain here for the
afternoon in the meantime let's cross
the Steve see how he's getting on with
his afternoon
thanks Justin he does have a very good
camouflage he went past where he was
this morning and I couldn't see him I
would not have known he was there if I
didn't know he is there
it was invisible invisible lipids that
is how it works once that camouflage is
given away then they need to move off
once they have been observed and that's
one of the reasons why you'll get
animals alarm cording is a group like
that because I see you I see you I see
you in the stealthy predator miss with
owls and birds of prey who also you got
there Davi so you also get hours and
birds of prey also get mobbed by birds
and they generally move away quite soon
afterwards because without their
stealthiness I think is there without
their stealthiness they um they are they
don't have the necessary ability to
catch anything you see the same with
cheaters cheaters the game's up lions
are quite similar as well they're all
sort of start like even in Ghana how
many times have I seen it in Ghana who's
kind of on the move and then he gets
spots he just like calling he's like I
got he's seen me it'll it okay so he's
just gonna go through the drainage
though there seems to be no sign of
Sibley where she's got okay she's not
lying up down in the bottom me I do
apologize about our picture breakup that
we are experiencing now in the sand very
sandy it's gonna bumble through this
little drainage line she was left on the
other side of the dam this morning I
believe and she came from this side so
maybe she actually had some meat but she
definitely had some altercation with
Tandy that's what Tenley was behaving
the way she was behaving
but who knows if they actually came to
blows I didn't see either of them up
close this morning to Sabri for visual
of the Queen Tandy
hello Meighan well a links or a caracal
has also got points it is the what's yes
African Wildcats has got pointed ears
servoz got round is a lot of its got to
do with camouflage you know I mean
Caracol actually blends in beautifully
with these little points and Tufts on
the top of their head versus around ears
so that the pointed ears actually work
in camouflage a caracal is almost
invisible when it's staring straight at
your leopard in a lion for camouflage
flatten their ears to break up that
shape that they have so I think it's an
evolutionary trait that the family
itself or the group the species itself
has sort of evolved with domestic cats
they they're not really hiding from
anything they do sneak up on things but
they're not coming over termite mounds
over rises and having me like at iron or
Liberty tin garden with sonic puppet but
the Miss B to break up the cat line
outline where as a caracal taper there
is actually four so that's just me
speculating at all why domestic cats
which were once the African Wildcats
have been bred into sort of that and
maybe some people have even bred some
domestic cats to be very point about it
yeah I think maybe they like it not have
absentia
one of the mysteries of nature okay you
know go check the fire break one last
effort here forcibly and then we were
gonna go and see if we can find Tandy
where she was left this morning well
we're gonna get going around here one
more look forcibly and then we'll move
on to Tandy and let's go over to Lauren
who's also searching let's see how she's
getting one
while we moved on from our hippopotamus
we're a little bit of an interaction
with Winston Churchill oh we tried to
put him on camera but he comes so close
to the car to say hi that it's really
not possible to actually put him on
camera at all so we're gonna keep
bumbling on I do feel like taganas
around here somewhere and honestly I'm
not gonna lie to you it's not because
I've seen tracks or anything like that
it is just uh it's just a gut feeling
sometimes you get these weird feelings
out here and it is nothing more than
that
little squirrel are you able to get that
squirrel sense and off we go
I love how much squirrels run for their
lunch and their life sorry talking of
food I regularly enjoy eating raw papers
on my drive it's my thing a whole read
paper I think they are absolutely cuz he
have like already well well and truly
dived into the shredded paper and
everyone in camp in some utterly bonkers
for eating or just sit and eat them I
think they're so delicious
love raw papers but absolutely he could
curse everyone in Kenya up and the Maura
thought I was crazy as well and everyone
crazy do you all think I'm crazy
does anyone else eat raw peppers for a
snack or is it just me saying so also
yes hints is good in the back of my
vehicle well I think it's delicious I
think faith also agrees actually I'm
pretty sure a hair Gordon moon when she
saw me eating it
yeah faith love something - thanks fee
you've always got my bet
so we're just gonna bumble on a little
bit to worry pan
someone loves them was a backseat Bex
loves them all chopped up in her salad
raw yes I do like them chopped up but
sometimes you can all grow I don't have
the time to chop up a pepper so some
things you just have to munch the whole
thing home but I do like them chopped up
as well of course I do
so yes gory pan is up here and I think
it's pretty much dry but we often find
King Khan or Columbo here so I'm taking
a bit of a gamble to see if we can see
any sports around here oh it looks like
my boy is stalking again so we're gonna
send you across to Hassan Oh
I'm sure you'd like to be considered as
anybody's for son I think he's a free
roaming spirit but he's moving around I
think he's pretty pretty kind of tint on
hunting something whether or not it's
these impalas or something else I'm not
sure but you know that monkeys are
really shouting at him so it's gonna be
a bit tricky but he's gonna head up
towards those impalas unfortunately
we're gonna lose view of him completely
so you know condition ourselves and just
try and see if we can get something
performance it's gonna be a big bump
here Craig so just be sorry
unfortunately we need to try and wait
for everybody else to
[Music]
just to try and kind of shuffle around
and see what we can do but you'll
probably use this galley system as much
as he can if possible the galley system
allows him to be able to creep around
and move and kind of get into places
where he's able to hunt now from here
I'm not sure where he's gonna go I'm
hesitant to try and go up just from the
point of view that if these impalas are
on top right of where we are at the
moment we hit up there they're gonna
just push away from us so if we stop and
just wait a little bit it allows him to
move along and to kind of find where he
wants to go or so you never know the
impart is my turn and start heading back
towards night there they go they've
obviously seen him and off they go so
that is the end of hassanis hunt I'm
afraid he's going to have to now find
another way of doing things because
those impalas have now seen him spotted
him and are not very happy about the
fact that he's around so let's just see
where did he go though great sir next
questioner there was there
what is he stalking now going to the
toilets that's what Easter joy says I do
think he has good hunting skills I mean
he does miss a lot but so does every
leopard he just tries that much more
than a lot of other lipids he's a very
very active cat and he spends a vast
majority of his time going off to many
many many many many different animals
and so I don't consider him bird hunting
I just consider him to try more in
others and you can see now he's given up
on the pan it's too many things shouting
at him
so between monkeys and impalas it's not
time to head off somewhere else and he
does this seeming the most times that
he's at the pan he waits until the
afternoon which surprises me because
they often in theoretically should be a
great time to be at the pan because so
many things come and drink but she seems
to move off and then he does this big
loop and misses around and then
eventually will start hunting again
later in the sort of early hours of the
morning he's back at the pan and kind of
either resting while still looking for
food from there I'm just gonna try to
get through here this way roughly close
to where he was this morning he wasn't
too far from this area oh he's such a
pretty cat though he's gonna come
through right so here we are he's so
nice if he climbed up onto this dead
tree yeah that's fallen over and just
posed for us wouldn't that be lovely
it should come from our left hand side
there he comes
oh and boy up onto the tree I don't
think he's going to go onto the tree but
one can hope and wish see how he goes
when he goes over rises high keeps his
head down and just checks very carefully
it's a bit clever he knows that they
could very well be something like a dico
or Impala or Neos I mean like they're
just on the other side so when he
approaches anyway we can't see over the
top see how is he doing much there is
flatter and he tries to kind of creep up
as much as possible then kind of peer
over the top so as not to give himself
away too much once he's had a good scan
of the area you'll find you'll start to
walk again
and kind of move off and find something
else but you can see on his tummy now
that he's he's in need of some sort of a
meal what have you seen asana I don't
know what this cat's spots that we can't
look at him lipid corner and him back to
normal once he gets lower down you'll be
back to normal and kind of looking
around again but what it is that he saw
I have absolutely no idea because there
is nothing that I can see that's not to
say that he hasn't spotted something we
as humans are pretty blind when it comes
to watching lipids that's for sure
no seeing what lipids see I suppose they
were not watching lipids but seeing with
liquid see maybe cuz he's going around
towards the drainage let's go around
skyy how often does a lipids tail
movement give its presence away oh I
mean it does happen but not that often I
mean most the time the whites of the
tail is at the back and generally if
something gets very close in their tail
stops it's normally from afar that the
tail twitching is happening and once
they get a little bit closer then they
stop doing it so that's what he's
stalking you see there Craig is in
parlors this what we gonna do is we're
gonna sits and we in a position
ourselves right here where I can
somewhat see the impalas I'm pretty sure
what Hasan is gonna do is he's gonna go
down along the drainage line in order to
try and hunt these in parlors this there
is so he's walking down this is exactly
where I was walking around this morning
actually only enough looking for him and
the impalas are kind of on my right-hand
side so I don't want to move too much
we're just gonna sit here and watch
where he goes but the the cover of the
drainage lion is the perfect place for
him to be able to kind of stalk along
where we can't see him and you can see
that's already from what we're looking
at now is how once he gets down in there
it's very very difficult to make him out
you can just make out his back as he's
walking along and he's gonna try and get
himself closer and closer and closer
towards where these impalas are so I'll
just kind of stick where we are right
now we're not gonna move that's all I
don't want to off road any further let's
try and wait for him to get his way
closer towards where those impalas are
at the moment come on boy now don't go
up there because then you're going the
wrong way yes you need to come along the
drainage come along further
he's just trying to work it out NASA
trying to figure out okay where do I go
if he's in part is moving the Impala is
actually dropping towards the drainage
line which could potentially benefit him
if he moves quick enough and he gets to
where he needs to be fast enough then
maybe just maybe he'll be able to
position now just trying to watch where
he's going difficult to see obviously
designed to camouflage pretty well but
I'm pretty sure he's gonna get what runs
there between the grass is quite a steep
little [ __ ] and in there there's a
gully that he can walk along and the
gully goes all the way along and he can
then follow that gully
to the right-hand side which is there
he's just popped his head up now Craig
why don't you go down rather way it's
going to be better for you it was
decided this is the way he wants to go
but you can see highs concentrating in
terms of how far he's got to go he's got
probably about I would say 100 meters
that he needs to cover now before he's
going to be able to get any way near
where the impalas are so he needs to be
able to kind of go very very very slowly
from where he is now and try and get a
little bit closer once he gets to within
maybe 510 meters it's got a much better
shot at what he's doing but for now his
ability to get closer is gonna be what's
gonna make or break this hunter
I saw inked it'll be better off if he's
down below and where he is now a little
bit more exposed obviously we can see
him clearly but we're the impalas are
they weren't cm nearly as well because
in front of him is quite a lot of
vegetation that he's gonna hit into so
I'm not the worst place to hunt I
suppose
so we'll use a new year how much greater
is his sense of smell over humans I'm
not sure the exact figure and the exact
statistic but I can tell you it's much
much much much stronger I mean we walk
around Jen face salt and pick up a scent
of something where is these guys they'll
pick up a scent and they'll be able to
follow it for quite some time and
actually leads them to things and I've
watched lipids go for over four five
kilometers following a scent and leading
them to a kill their sense of smell is
infinitely stronger than what ours is
but what the actual figure is no
statistic or what parts they can pick up
a million I'm not 100% sure to be honest
with you but I'll have a look and see
I'm sure this is a statistic out there
some way but you can see how he's kind
of creeping along at the moment slowly
making his way and you can see what I'm
talking about about how thick it is in
front of me so that's the thickets there
and it doesn't stay thick like that
unfortunately as we pan towards the
right and towards where the impalas are
you can see it opens art and in the
impalas it just through that gap they
can you just make them out cut through
this thicket so he's got a long way to
cross but unfortunately very little
cover from here to where they are so
what he's gonna do is he's gonna get
himself into spots like years now park
off inside there and then wait for the
impalas to move around and the sort of
cover of darkness will probably be the
base thing and that Sun is starting to
set now so it'll be good for him just to
be patient and to try and kind of wait
until it gets a little bit more dark and
dingy the problem is is the impalas are
not gonna stay here until until it's
pitch black
they're gonna start moving out of this
area because they know it's much more
dangerous for them to be in here at
night then it is during the course of
the day but I still haven't seen him
emerge from his little a policed area
sighs coming now
yeah most definitely that how to provost
hell does its own thing altogether it
seems to have a mind of its own
so it'll twitchin and move and kind of
go even when the rest of his body is
motionless his tail will twitch and
that's just all kind of it's a
excitement and an indication probably
more than anything if it's a female two
cubs to stop moving and to not come
where she is so that twitching of the
tail would be a good signal remember
that back end of their tail is white and
so it's easy for a cub to see and so
that's probably where it comes from and
then that behavior is learned as they
get a bit older but look at him go isn't
that cool it amazes me the camouflage
that they have when they get into this
dry wintery grass
problem that he's got now is he's
reached the sort of limits of where
there's cover for him from where he is
now to where the impala are is
completely open at this stage so what
he's got a hopeful is rutting male in
parlors that cause havoc in amongst the
herd and chase each other all over the
place
now you can see as he's walking me and
look how much more exposed he is already
and that's because there's no more grass
cover there's no more bushes and he's
trying to what he trying to do is use
this one quarry Bush between the impalas
and him at the moment he's trying to use
that as his kind of cover to stalk a
little bit closer but he's got a long
long way to go still before he's even
anywhere near a strike zone or anywhere
where he can lie down and wait and be
patient so there it can probably another
good 15 20 minutes of stalking and
moving painfully slowly in order to get
himself anywhere near where those
impalas are
we'll just have to be patient and just
see how it goes it's one of those things
where the patience is a virtue of this
poison and particularly when cats hunt
one needs to be patient search all over
the universe I didn't exactly but I
think it was something along the lines
is easy larger than Tenggara it's no not
by a long shot
he's it's not quite a lot smaller wider
I'm not sure what you mean by wider to
be honest don't know if talking about
his lengths or his breaths or his head
or his body I'm why there's not really a
term we use with lipids as he as long as
a desert in Ghana probably fairly close
to height wise note no Enya and bulk
wires no in you yet I'm afraid it's
still got a long way to go and both
accounts when it comes to Tooting Ghana
so the stage knife he's not in any way
close to the width of I don't know
whatever comparison we making he's not
there I mean even his track width is not
as big as tingitana so there's really
nothing about him that's wider than 10
Ghana at this stage asana you've boxed
yourself into a corner here my way
because you've gotten into a place where
no you can't really move which is not
ideal for him I still think if he had
followed the drainage along he would
have been far bit off and he could have
popped up in that little thicket just in
front of him you can just start to make
it out on the right side of the frame
there there's a little kind of thicket
you see it there if he had followed the
drainage you could have popped into that
thicket and then he would have been very
very close and if there's an parlours
moved they would have moved roughly kind
of towards where he is yeah the problem
is is that the presence of vehicle yeah
there's two vehicles on the other side
means the impalas are not feeding which
allows him no room to move if they start
to feed and they drop their heads it's
much easier for him to kind of get
closer and be able to get in where he
needs to so we'll just have to be
patient and wait and like I said he's
getting darker so things will start
getting easier for asana could will be
patients in a sit here in the meantime
there I'm gonna send you across to
Steve who is still tracking subway
ace tristan well we checked the fire
break everybody and we found tracks of
well most likely said we heading in a
westerly direction along the fabric and
then they cut back and now the track
seems to sort of hit this wall that this
is where I found Tandy this morning kind
of hit this wall tree house dam is just
up here so we're hoping we hoping we're
gonna find him because well she didn't
deaf you didn't cross arch she didn't go
south she came back and she started
walking you see yeah attendees tracks
this morning just on the road you'll see
this Matt I do apologize history tracks
this morning that we're steaming is
Herbie likes to call him and there's my
footprints next them
I followed her down here and then she
materialized out the end of this block
it's very exciting but now the boys
tracks have come in this direction and
she was st. marking down the road then I
checked that Road they were no tracks
this morning so are we gonna be like he
does sobrino about tree house down
probably can smell it can probably smell
it
but so shabbat Tunney moves along here
she might move just along the different
angle may put Steve mark eight their
territories so see now you want to know
which African catches the best parents
wow there's a very good question well
cheetahs seem to be the the least
successful because they're just not
strong enough to to sort of defend their
cubs if they do have them leopard
solitary parents so they do the best
that they can and lions well they're in
a pride so they have a little bit more
help when it comes to supporting the
youngsters but be very hard to really
save all in all I think cats do quite
badly when it comes to looking after
their youngsters it's just the way it is
you know you look at dogs and hyenas and
they have a little bit more success
because of the fact that they use
burrows in the ground and that's an
evolutionary adaptation that many many
mammals have utilized for not only the
survival of their young but the survival
of themselves and while lions haven't
done it or leopards is beyond me going
into aardvark holes so it's very hard to
really put a number on that but cats for
the most part leopards seem to do a
little bit better than cheetah but I
really wouldn't know how to put a number
on that each environment you go to will
have different success rates the
Serengeti does very well for cheetah cuz
the environment cheetah don't do very
well because the environments is hard to
put like a the cold hard facts around it
mmm but lines in the Kruger when I
worked on the east side the Kruger they
did very well they were just killing
machines prides of 24 25 lions 16 cubs
surviving at a time and then little calm
is here I haven't had a good couple - -
couple years but then Tandy's having a
consecutive one cub sort of litter going
through so anyway let's grass Tristen
what he thinks about which of the big
cats
got the best success rate with hiccups
Oh hmm it's a tricky one I suppose I
mean I don't think cheetah unfortunately
is high up on that list given their
inability unfortunately to even defend
cubs if something attacks and they are
close by it's a tough one I think it
depends a lot on the area and the
density of predators that could
potentially be dangerous to their cubs
as to which ones are successful in
certain sections so you know in areas
where there's very low density of hyena
lion so then obviously if it's - quite
well and so do you Cheeta say probably
you'd find that there's more success in
in lions just from a pride point of view
so once they get past that sort of most
difficult phase where they relying so
heavily on mom in a den I won't say
actually with the pride then it's much
easier for many of the pride females to
protect the little ones from various
threats oh it's a probably lions and but
even then the percentage of cubs that
survive to adulthood is very similar to
that of lipid so I don't know if I mean
serve all of those also the same issues
it's it's tricky and lacks it depends
very heavy on the environment that
they're in and the number of other
predators that are around them in it
definitely here in the sabi sands I
would say if you were to look at it I
would say lines probably have a higher
percentage than the lipids you think
about how many litters of lipids are
lost and a changeover of males it's
quite a lot more than the lines at the
moment the Lions it's really just the
birmingham's a lot - a male the Salalah
males male should I say and then the
work is north and south so I would say
probably Lions have it's the easiest at
the moment and probably make the best
mothers now it's not to say that they
aren't very good mothers lipids in the
Soviets and I just think they have a
much tougher time with far more male
lipids in
and and in the area then what the Lions
have to deal with and remember that in
both those species generally male lion
or male leopard in those species is the
number one cause for Cubs to be lost
it's not it's not so much other
predators for both of them you can see
the little white tip of Hasan Azia is
not made us and will move since you last
saw him he's just watching these impalas
the impalas are slowly starting to relax
now which is good news the quieter it is
and the more things kind of take on the
more they forget about the fact that
there's cars and various other things
and so they starting to slowly kind of
go back to feeding and making themselves
pretty comfortable and personna then
he's able to kind of move a step forward
every time but the problem is is there's
one in parlor to the right which is the
male Impala who is kind of stopping any
sort of movement for horse owner Linda I
think animal stomachs growl when they
hungry lakhs of humans probably probably
find that there's some sort of noises
that come out of the stomachs and we
never that close that we can really hear
too much sometimes hear them when they
sleeping so much that they almost
snoring but in terms of growling tummy's
very very seldom most of the time with
these cats you know we're not close
enough to be able to hear it I would be
very very surprised though if they don't
I'm almost certain that their tummies do
growl when they're a little bit hungry
especially when they see a pay source
moving around very very close to where
they are
was Hana I still think you should have
been in the drainage most of those in
parlors are moving into the drainage
gnarling you would have been prime
position to have hunted them they're
coming down from right to left at the
moment you can see all messiahs head has
changed and tilted slightly so I think
he would have been perfect if you'd
stayed down there but who knows maybe
there wasn't enough cover and that's why
I opted for the more Thor sort of
thicker Bank area in the drainage itself
what we really need those two boys to
start fighting in the mail in parlors
and that'll scatter the herd in every
direction and then Kasana will have the
ability to running in the chaos and grab
potentially a prey animal good well
again it's the patient's game so he's
just gonna keep sitting in the meantime
there Lauren is driving straight towards
the sunset and I hope that there's a pot
of gold at the end
I am driving into the sunset and since
the Sun is going down the big ball of
orange fire has disappeared but Sainz is
gonna give you a beautiful view of the
horizon in front of us were actually on
a bit of a well go down an incline if
you like so we're going down a slope and
it gives us a perfect view over the
whole landscape here look at that
and according to my moon at its ninety
nine point four percent fool so I think
that well and truly classifies us filmin
tonight it's on the other side of us now
so we can't give you a view of the moon
but I'm sure someone will at some point
during the drive now of course this is
the time when a lot of animals start
stirring nocturnal animals start waking
up becoming alive becoming hungry I
think that's what Tristan's question was
just about do animals get angry when
they're hungry or something yeah I'm
sure they do
I'm sure animals get hangry just like we
do I definitely get grumpy when I'm
hungry a hundred percent I really don't
like to be hungry so we've covered quite
a lot of the reserve and not a single
track to be seen other than Impala and
ginormous hippo tracks so we're just
gonna move inwards to the reserve and
just keep bumbling and see what we see
obviously it will get dark on us pretty
soon so I'm trying to cover as much
distance as I can while the light is
still with us because it makes it just
that but easier to see and then it goes
into that sort of Twilight Zone where I
really struggle to see anything and then
as soon as it goes dark then you of
course have your spotlight and it gets a
little bit easier again so since let's
bumble on I think he's enjoying the
sunset a little bit too much I want to
see what we can see up ahead
hehas asking do I still get an
adrenaline rush when a leopard walks
past the car absolutely I think
everybody saw that yesterday I got
really exciting I just couldn't believe
it
it's we actually spoke about this from
the fire last night little bit of a
bonfire and a Bry
Conrad's parents are with us and the
Coupe de Bry I had vegetables of course
but and we were discussing it this is
what the push is all about yes there are
quiet things and it's hard it's hard
looking and not being able to find
something but then you just have this
magical moment and not that was
yesterday for me you know just feeling
some things happen and you can't put
your finger on it but that's what they
train you to be out here so listen Luke
smell me especially I can smell lions
and just try to figure I what's going on
around you the environment is telling
new things
you just have to look listen and smell
you you can figure it out and it's not
easy obviously especially when you're
driving you're listening to directors
and game drive radios and your cake cam
ops it's really not easy but once you
just really tuned in on what's happening
around you the environment will tell you
things and laws and parler yesterday
just just spoke and all of a sudden
husana appeared and what we were
discussing yesterday was if I hadn't
stopped for the Impala see I was busy
looking down this way four tracks had it
notice them saying so and I would have
driven and husana would have popped
right behind us and we would have never
have seen him and it's it's all about
Simon it's all about luck it's just all
about getting things right oh I see the
moon and we promised you the moon so
we're giving you the Sun and the moon in
one V one shot if you like wow look at
that perfect sounds good job I love it
when you see the moon when it's still
light not as full moon full moon for
Father's Day so it's gonna be a very
light there's gonna be a lot of ambient
light around tonight for TV so hopefully
we're gonna bump into a few more
nocturnal animals
full moon obviously has the biggest
impact on the ocean as well that creates
bigger greater differences between high
and low tide spring tides and that has a
big impact on the animal life in the
ocean as well and of course out here
there just will be a lot more light and
we've discussed us many times before I
think with you all but I do not sleep
well when it's full moon so I'm probably
in for a night or interrupted I sleep a
lot of tossing and turning tonight which
is not great I love my food and I love
my sleep but for some reason when it's
full moon I just have the most awful
sweeps out of the whole month it's
always around full moon and I just
cannot sleep
let's bumble on while I answer this
fantastic question because we have to
find some animals for you old Michaels
asking since I can smell lines foot not
pleasant when was a few weeks ago we
knew one of the Avoca males was it
before sir damn and we took a big risk
we'd been there already in the drive if
any of you were watching and we took a
big risk to go back just as the Sun was
said and to see if the lion might wake
up because we didn't know where he was
we knew he was in the vicinity but
everybody lost track of him
and it just worked again another risk
time and luck we got there this lion oh
my goodness I can't even begin to
explain I could smell him approach and I
knew he was on his way they offer the
order is awful
it's a very Orangery brown disgusting
order of lions no lines are fantastic
but oh they smell they really do smell
because either way it's not pleasant so
we're crossing the Milwaukee the snow
and I'm just having a lude because
obviously that's a favorite haunt of
many of our animals just to see if I can
see any tracks heading up this way but I
cannot so we're gonna keep hitting on
whites but yes I am smell I don't get
the same smell from leopards
I really don't I've obviously spent a
lot of time and going back to I think it
was kales question or the adrenaline I
don't think I'll ever get bored of it
you know what I don't even think Tristan
does or Jamie does who's been doing it
for a long time when you get that moment
where an animal just appears in front of
you it's incredible
especially when you really don't expect
it and I had it in the Mara as well with
Manu when we were just hoping that we
would see leopards but you know it
wasn't guaranteed and he was seen should
be leave you know it's it's not very fun
just standing around waiting and all of
a sudden two leopards popped our mother
and a son and it's just that feeling
I'll never ever ever get bored about
it's incredible because this is their
environment this area does not belong
to us it's not for human habitation I
guess it is there's and we're just
visitors so of course when our animal
pops out like that it is just absolutely
incredible claw Lamba did its me a few
weeks ago I was driving along and she
just popped out and from the car
amazing alrighty so I'm gonna go right
and you guys are gonna go across to see
and see if he thinks lion smell
Lions do ever quite a quite a pong to
them but so do leopards I've actually
been close enough to touch both of them
and they both smell horrible
so do I eNOS all through them they smell
really really bad that's the reason why
they were all in Buffalo dung and
elephant dung - two masks they're very
very pungent death like rotten carrion
smell we were talking earlier about how
Conrad got woken up in the middle of the
night for his smell of a you know
outside his door he reckons had probably
slips inside of a carcass somewhere it
rots an elephant or hippo or something
strange like that but you can actually
well I was checking in corners and their
vocal mail at while ago you could
actually smell where they'd been you
could smell Lions yeah so they do leave
that sense on this on the floor I think
the the the smell might be but
noticeable because it's a pride but one
on one lions and leopards have got a
very similar sort of stench to them to
them though they're quite unique to them
their smell uniquely different and
they're able to tell each other apart
through smell which I find quite amazing
you know like some people can say I know
what my dad smells like you smell your
dad's jacket when you miss him being
Father's Day no of course you know a dad
smells like hyenas know every member of
the clan and lions and every member of
the pride they know them and when they
smell something that they don't
recognize oh just dodge your life there
then they know and then they fight or
they run away either way who's up we
have the hyenas well walk up to wherever
Columbus been sitting her oh I know this
leopard I can steal from her or visiting
garden I going on might not mess with
you
Lee it's a great question I suppose if
they had the foresight to design or
develop the perfume they would do so but
humans got by without perfume for very
long time you just just deal with it
didn't you
there's nothing they can do about this
smell really sorry they just live with
it but they do mask their smell as often
as they can by rolling in the dung of
other animals because they know in
parlor and kudu and they can pick up a
sense of a lion or a leopard on the
breeze and it just makes them go a
little bit crazy so they know that's a
fact what these animals were the
predator death like smell smells like
and so they will mask their scent but I
don't think they do it out of any common
courtesy for themselves or for each
other
I do it merely as the more concealment
for the approach towards some food okay
so while we searched around for sea buoy
and we think she might still be in the
block nothing came out a tree house
watching halt what's going on here
there's a very small colony behind mum
so small you can't even really see it
Darby you got it let me just move back
behind that in front of that branch
there's a very small little youngster
hello ma'am and what's really
interesting is father at birth and
yaller at birth and a lot of these small
little animals give off even though
they've come out of Mom's womb out of
her placenta and all of that they've got
no scent in the early stages which is a
defense against the very very well tuned
nose of a predator I found that
incredible how can something be born
that's lived inside of an animal for
months and months and months and come
out with no odor I mean you just wear
your shoe for a day and you try to take
your foot out of his sock after one day
and they have no smell that's impossible
it's impossible maybe it's just my shoes
but I'm not sure but anyway a leopard
who likes to hunt small a little baby in
y'all
is nowhere near us at the moment we're
looking for Tandy now let's go back over
to Tristan and at the little chief
indeed I think asana would be very very
happy with the baby now unfortunately
for him the impalas all meandered off
that's a rather fast speed and he's been
left behind a little bit and neither
sitting kind of looking around thinking
plotting his next move that's for sure
so I don't know if he's going to follow
those impalas again I somehow think that
he's gains you probably at all
likelihood just sitting on a plot his
next move maybe give up on those impalas
and go and find something else there's a
good place for him to be though because
there's every likelihood of him getting
something like a jawline here like Steve
has got more potential you little dico
or something like that so be interesting
to see what he ends up doing if he
abandons the Impala hunt or if he
decides to start moving but look up for
T's looking either nobody's golden back
to us is crates is very very dark when
it starts to get into this light it's
quite interesting to kind of see how how
much darker he appears earlier when he
was in the sort of sunlight appeared
more sort of yellowy but here's a little
kind of gold orange the darker it gets
right let's catch up with him and see
whether or not he's going to continue
his hunt
I suspect however that's we're going to
go for a long walk now
and we're going to be dragged through
all kinds of thickets that's Mehsana
likes to walk in from here it's
generally not a very comfortable ride
and of course it is what's the time now
take half an hour to go until we finish
the show and then another so an hour and
so he starts the next one it's going to
be a long hour I can assure you of us
being tracked to thickets he makes us
work for his viewing which is fair
enough I suppose it's probably in the
contract in the fine print that one must
follow and go through thickets in order
to pass the tests as to whether or not
he goes on to the big screen although he
was far more obliging last year last
year he was he was very happy
beyond the screen maybe that's because
that was United States television and
not South African television maybe he
teams things to be a bit different if
it's South African television I don't
know
certainly isn't the same as he was last
year he was just on every single TV show
this year he's kind of you know not that
face maybe he's trying to get away from
the certain Liberty lifestyle over the
course of the next for the last few
months and it's you know slow ease back
into
celebrityhood for her sana what have you
seen now everywhere he goes he seems to
spot things that he wants to go after
and look at a chase and do all kinds of
things to you thinking Paul is writing
in front of us here there's an update
just now of a big male lipid on buffers
hope but it sounded like very far north
or wonder if it's maybe not in Ghana
that's all the way up that side are you
possible no don't go up that Bank don't
go up that Bank I have to speak to him
tell him not to be seriously yo sana of
all the places
it's really there's no way to follow him
where he's going now absolutely nothing
can I think now whether we gamble and go
back up onto the bank or we stay inside
the drainage the problem is is up on
that Bank I can't follow him at all
and down here it's also going to be
quite tricky I think let's stick with
him down here and then we'll try and see
if he cuts more towards the other way
he'll be hitting closer towards turn
dams good we need to try and figure out
a way to keep up with him in the
meantime though let's send you across to
Lauren you're still bubbling and hoping
that's maybe his dad pops out look who
we have a tree house damn now on purpose
16 quiet because these animals as many
of you know are extremely skittish we
actually rarely come across something
I've tried to get them on camera so many
times and it's a case of what we Fremen
up and in off it goes this is of course
a tiger and this is actually the same
type of animal Oksana has tried to hunt
today and yesterday now it's obviously
came them to the waterhole
those three high Stein water hole is
right next to us and it's cautiously
moving we now dijkers are obviously
small enough they're much smaller than
your Impala
that's although seeing that the females
are much better than the males
it's one of the few animals other than
hyenas where you find that but Tigers
are obviously small enough that it's
more beneficial for them to actually be
on their own than be inherits now if you
look at the view we've got right now the
coloration actually blends and quite
well to the back room there of course we
can still see it but it's its height
it's so small as short that when it
walks in the tall grass it actually
completely disappears so this is a
really cool sighting for me it's not
very often since I was laughing at me
but it's actually not very often you get
a sight
like that's with the dycar because they
are so skittish they're also said to be
monogamous as well so just like the
steam Bach you to also find them in
monogamous pairs bridging pairs it
doesn't mean they're always necessarily
together as I'm side-by-side like a lot
of birds and fish are but normally they
will have a partner that they solely
breeds well and be they will be in the
same sort of territory they don't always
need to be side by side but it's said
that they generally do always know where
their partner is lovely now we very
often see them when we're driving
nighttime and we're using our spotlight
you often see a lot of bikers their eyes
reflecting back at us and they really
Nestle themselves in amongst the
vegetation and they're so well heading
you can literally only see their eyes
glaring back at you
think you'll have to repeat that I know
what you're saying I thought I heard
fairytale princess that I could be
completely wrong
[Music]
I did hear a perfect fairytale princess
um I guess so
why not princess tiger I'm really really
trying to be quiet yeah because the
minute we turn on the engine or I move
too fast it's gonna get afraid and just
run off and I really don't want to scare
it too much so I am trying to whisper a
little bit but yes princess tiger I like
it but I know what you mean they're very
elegant obviously got very short horns
on the top of their head and you can see
the way the dijkers moving you're very
very slowly only one foot at a swing can
you see that only one leg at a time what
a student is register and what that
means is when the front foot moves the
back foot on the same side it's gonna
move and the foot will land in the exact
same spot that the front foot was him
did that make any sense so the tracks
the back track will land and the front
fruit struck I really hope that made
sense and that is called register and
and that's what is - and it's a method
that the antelope use when they're
really trying to be quiet so the front
foot or go the back foot will follow and
land in that exact position and that's
what this little duikers doing and have
completely lost sight of it because it's
getting to that time of night and it's
obviously very about camouflage it is
around here but of course as soon as we
get closer it's gonna disappear anyway
yeah that was such a lovely sight in for
me a little die cut okay we're gonna
bumble on I'm not sure where we're gonna
head jab we're gonna take it as it comes
but you guys will come back across to
Tristan and Hosanna
I was with Hassan and he's well he is
kind of just sitting so we haven't moved
really because I'm trying to see which
way he's gonna go if he goes in front of
him so if he walks to his right
this essentially then he is going to be
walking towards twin dams Road but if he
comes down to his left then we need to
stay in the drainage if he goes straight
and I'm not really sure what's gonna
happen so we kind of need to try and
figure out which way he's going to go at
this stage just thinking to myself I
don't know it's tricky cuz he keeps
looking over his shoulder
initially thought was set like that that
he was gonna walk out of the drainage in
a way which would have been nice first
but keeps looking kind of down there
which is not ideal for us I'm not sure
where he's gonna go from here we'll just
be patient and see for now we've got a
nice view of him which is wonderful it's
quite wonderful said to listen to the
radio and listen to how people are
talking about where this lipid is
walking currently sitting dead still
there's no one else with us quite seem
impressed that people know which way
he's heading given that they're not even
in the siting and I haven't given an
update it's quite funny actually they
say new people in all kinds of
directions and well he's sitting dead
still at the stage so I'm gonna have to
probably interrupt that conversation at
some point but for now it's just making
me giggle inside to listen to what is
being told to others that's another
story so when the noise quietens down
I'll eventually correct what's going on
but for now it's good just to indulge a
little bit more Tiana
isn't it such a nice thing to see his
kind of profile once again on the banks
of the mall RT you know it's been months
that's you know he's been away and to
sit and see him on the edge of the the
drain it's just kind of in his familiar
pose where he sits on his bum and looks
out over the bushes as always so
pleasant now a lot of you are saying
it's so nice to spend so much time with
him it's very pleasant isn't it I
thoroughly enjoy spending time with him
and I know that everybody else does too
I mean Lauren loves it and so does Steve
and James and Jamie and there's no one
really that's part of this fire live
team that doesn't want to spend time
with lisanna
and so we fortunate in that we have a
lipid that gives us the quality of
sightings that wasana does that all of
us can enjoy not just us but the cam ops
and the you know even our directors and
everyone in camp as well as all of you
at home so very very lucky that we have
a lipid like him what amazes me though
with Hassan it's a weird thing is that
when he's not around it seems as though
we have far less lipid sightings it's an
odds phenomenon so we were struggling
for lipids for days yesterday he arrives
back here again after disappearing for
three days and all of a suddent in Ghana
and tandi's here and in this morning
Tandy and subbu ye are here so it's
weird how when he's around it just seems
like our other lipids seem to show
themselves that much more it's it's
obviously complete coincidence when it
comes to the females but I think his
presence does draw out Singh on a lot
more I mean to $14 to hang around this
area whether that then in turn because
of his vocalizing drawers out hook amore
and potentially that skittish male I
don't know it's obviously you know
completely yes and really there's no
facts based and what causes asanas but
it's easy kind of show up in everybody
else excuse me to make themselves known
as well so either way though I'm
thankful for if it's quite nice that the
fact that he's around and many other
lipids show face as well it always makes
life
easier for us in many respects when he's
mean he's here not only is there solid
sighting that generally lasts for long
periods but also like I say it tends to
coincide with a nice heightened period
hopefully another lipid pops out soon I
know shame Steve has been tracking all
afternoon Lauren's been looking hard so
hopefully one of the girls decides to
pop out because differently is ting
garner upon before so Ken he's far he's
not close at all he's basically on a new
road called east-west cut line hunters
mean axis now driving time from there
would be probably about 15 minutes or so
maybe not they can see where they are
let's see if they find us looking in
this direction with their lives
Ben is the bird that's calling alarm
calling no folktale drongos there is
pill spotted islets there's various
other birds that are calling but not
alarm calling at him Oh sana all right
he's gone the completes wrong way but
the way that we're gonna have to try and
find him now is gonna be not easy at all
sorry Craig tricky
a thief
terribly sorry about Tristan's technical
issues there everybody just going to
pick up something that's on the floor
yeah sure
you're gonna get a moment to see David
samples the guy ready for him here he
comes
there is hey give us our Davi woo yeah
don't know what that is it looks like a
lid of some sort
someone's top for their thermos flower
flask I'll try and find out who that
belongs to
gotta pick everything up in the bush at
least it's pink so it stood out quite
well okay buddy well we are driving down
the roads here and II was lost in the
block yeah
maybe maybe I come up cause she's
definitely hungry she's moving around a
lot as far as hours of wish she hadn't
eaten anything so maybe she's gonna move
around hopefully we'll be lucky because
we do have officer or a TV show this
evening and face I think I'm ready to
reveal the pole when you're already with
the answers there of who the most
beautiful leopard is you already do the
most beautiful female leopard is at the
moment on Juma
so faith there you go again with that I
know you said you're ready but I missed
the end of your sentence but you can
start giving me their percentages
while we scan the darkness Tsuboi in
fourth place with 15% Tandy and third s
with 18% okay this is gonna be between
cassava or the lumber everybody well
someone has got 24% and someone has got
43 or 42% and overall winner of the most
beautiful female leopard currently on
dreamer
are you ready Darby for the drumroll
goes to claw she is so beautiful she is
such a youngster now she is my choice
most beautiful I've only seen could
shower handful of times us and I think a
lot of looking at a lot of the
presenters as they I think also there's
a little bit of bias with regards to who
we do see who we get to see a lot sebou
e le believes is the prettiest so you
know I mean I suppose if we happen to
show Sabri a lot more and kochava a lot
more then I think they might feature a
little bit higher in their tally there
but Keshava did quite well but I do
think that Columba is the prettiest
prettiest of them all at the moment it
was a very pretty lady and she's still
only growing into her feet a little way
to go just a little clumsy to the lumber
that I had a couple of nights ago and
she gave me a very hard time trying to
follow her north
alarum or Columbo is perfection
well I I don't know about all of you
back home but I have been super blessed
and super privileged in the year and a
half that I've been here to spend the
amount of time I've spent with her I
mean I can't say I've spent that much
time with her this year and a couple
months towards the end of last year when
I was in the Mara but the early stages
of her growth Wow I was so so blessed
and I think all of us here to spend time
with a cab watching her grow watching
her sort of grow into the little
youngster that she is now the
independent sort of youngster that she
is has been an absolute treat for me
I've spent a fair bit of time with
leopards in the past but never to the
degree that we do here at Safari laughs
you know we we whenever I worked at a
lodge we haven't really developed the
characters the same sort of way and we
haven't seen the same Leopard every
single day sabi sands is like that I
suppose I haven't worked for the sabi
sands for any extended period of time so
that's probably why we were chatting day
of an hour early and Dave was saying
it's so disappointing that some
gardeners so skittish on foot and I said
that's a leopard that's what leopards
like on foot they run away it's just
what they do we're very blessed yeah
that we've managed to spend so much time
tracking prasanna and obviously it was
his mom before gorillas and then
shangilia the sister of asada and many
other leopards that are just very
relaxed to human presence which we're
very privileged to have it's just one of
those places in the world we just can't
beat it I know that there's two groups
driving out of where it's at at the
moment that I here specifically to
photograph our leopards so they were
very interested in finding asana last
night of course they were kissing
Lauren's feet when she found him and
then this morning they were very happy
when we got them into the same area as
ton D so very very nice now what we need
to do is find ting Ghana
ting Ghana does know it's TV day here
the email maybe he came early he was
here yesterday you came early and as now
I don't know if you knew about that but
he arrived yes then it's Justin found
him quite quickly just around the corner
here of course and just the city's
looking in absolutely fine form he's
looking well-fed he's looking bulky and
he was also looking very sort of what's
the word like like a beast of interest
and said I think he's been boxing people
in the north and he's come back like
prize fighter afterwards won a few
battles come back to to sort of stake
claim once again he was calling a lot
last night but then again he left this
morning so maybe you didn't leave maybe
the tracks we followed of another
leopard all together
okay well Lauren's busy scanning for
spotlights with for whoever she could
find let's go ask her she thinks the
prettiest of the lady lipids are
this back on I'm sorry by that I keep it
in my pocket and I think sometimes I
push on this switch so faith what was
that prettiest leopard cutest leopard I
guess that's maybe the same thing I know
who I'm gonna say though prettiest
Futaba 100%
I mean she's absolutely stunning her
eyes I mean they're all beautiful don't
get me wrong it's very hard to pick but
kochava is absolutely stunning for me
she's a prettiest can be not so much
there's definitely a fierceness to her
so I was saying earlier but I don't
think he heard me because my mic pack
was off we found tracks that look really
fresh they're on top of vehicle tracks I
feel that someone could be here in the
form of a spotted cat so we're still at
tree house we didn't actually go very
far since the last time we're gonna get
a flash I feel like someone could be in
this area but the tracks go off so they
leave the road and they go off which is
why I'm trying to drive really slowly
and shine into the thicket so at least
everybody is there we could potentially
get a glimpse of the reflective eyes now
tree house I've mentioned this on a few
occasions seems to be the waterhole that
has the healthiest cleanest source of
water other than the pans before soup
doesn't look too great especially with a
boy there that keeps good thing on a
daily basis and twin dams is very very
dry so tree house is definitely the best
which is what makes me think this would
actually be the ideal place for a
leopard to be
jain's is asking about the cat species I
spent time with in the Amazon I do think
I may have mentioned as one of my drives
but I actually spent well I don't know
if spending time as a correct phrase to
use because it wasn't a lot of time but
yes we were right next door I left in
the middle of the Ecuadorian Amazon with
absolutely nothing no fresh running
water no electricity just a generator
and water that we had taken with us and
we left with some shaman it was a crazy
amazing experience and there was a
family of Jaguars a mother had actually
just given birth not too far from hello
little duiker don't worry I'm not gonna
not gonna terrify you any further I mean
the mother had actually just given birth
to Cubs so we were in a tricky position
because the shaman were a little bit
worried you know that obviously female
cats will be way more aggressive when
they brought Cubs that they need to
protect but we did manage to see them
from a distance and glorious wonderful
stunning animals now I didn't spend time
with them like we do here and that's why
we're very privileged here I think Steve
was even talking about that earlier
because we really eat but we really are
able to spend time with these animals
and watch them and learn about their
daily habits and I personally feel we
have actually learned more than what you
can learn from a textbook just by
observations so it wasn't quite as
intimate as what we have here at safari
live but yes spent playing with the
Tigers and they're just absolutely
gorgeous and when I say we left in the
middle of nowhere we lived in the middle
of nowhere and we got lectured every
night by the shaman do not wander off on
your own even for a piece stop or
whatever stop don't do it if you get
lost in the Ecuadorian or any part of
the Amazon you will not find your way
back I think a movie the Harry Potter
guy what's his name Daniel Radcliffe's I
think he actually just made a movie on
that and you know there is no path it's
um it's so dense it's you know you you
take the wrong turn and how
more tankers is this where you guys hang
outs clearly yeah you're never gonna
find your way back and how do you
survive out there what do you do can't
remember what that movie was called with
Daniel Radcliffe it's a new one and it's
fantastic and it is about people getting
lost in an Amazonian jungle and one
actually survives but I mean oh that
would be a pretty harrowing experience
oh there are there's lots of things that
could potentially kill you I am gonna
Google that movie so that can tell you
all you can have a little watch so I won
all along I can't see the tracks anymore
but anyway we're gonna keep looking and
while I do that
we'll send you back to Tristan and
hosiah well some miracle or luck I'm not
sure which one it is has shown up down
on us because we have bumped into husana
in the most fluke fashion ever we lost
him completing you he did circuits round
and round and round and eventually we
came to little crossing in the Milwaukee
and Craig said is that a track for him
there in front so I'm trying to
reposition and look at this track and
I'm bending over and I've got to like
down low kind of checking out and then
Craig and I both look up and Hassan is
just staring at us in front of us on the
road as if to say what are you two
idiots doing I'm right here I haven't
come yet and I've been waiting for you
anyway it's got funny at the time it was
not and how he kind of bumped into him
at that point that I have no idea what
have you seen boy just turn my lights
off so that we don't disrupt him I did
go past a scrub here a little bit
earlier in this area so maybe that's
what he saw but like I say the
likelihood of us bumping into him was I
mean it was just right time right place
if we had driven there five minutes
earlier or five minutes later we would
have completely missed him and it would
have been a very difficult task to find
him so we got very lucky in many
respects to be able to catch up with him
again
and he's being very nice that he's
walking in them all right you know as we
speak and stopping and posing for it's a
little bit so good by dinner hasn't he's
still on the hunt as you can see I mean
by his whole behavior
he walks walks walks walks and any noise
he'll just turn and kind of look and all
of a sudden if something will grab his
attention so I'm pretty sure he's gonna
keep hunting through the course of the
evening I believe a lots of you're very
excited that we managed to find him I
can promise you and not too many more
excited in faith on the radio because
then we have this TV show coming up in
the moment we have when we lost him we
were staring down a dire hour where we
againts have to try and pull a rabbit
out the Hat and so I'm pretty sure that
we're all pretty happy that he's come
out and I tell you what I I'm more happy
than most because the last two weeks of
s ABC TV shows I have followed ting
Ghana and he has crossed office property
and I followed her Camry for the entire
engine his fire and also crossed over
just as we started so it really is nice
to have a cat rights in the sense of
humor but now I've got to make sure that
I keep him and on top of that the other
problem is is that we're walking south
there with much speed at this rate
there's if he keeps this up I'm not
quite so sure he'll still be yet for the
entirety of the show that let's see how
we go it might be Murphy's Law it's
gonna get you slowly because of our area
Thank You Craig Craig is manning the
aerial with much much masterful ninja
skill
[Music]
to Lana other than the fact that they
all come from different places
body odor scent marking and urine are
basically very very different things
body odor is caused by the bacteria that
is left when you sweat and where is
scent marking it is pretty much urine
it's just the act of marking territory
that is called st. marking so it's
spraying urine that contains chemicals
that signals to other animals within
that area that they are there is a
territorial individual or an individual
and they can calculate who they are
within their environment it's very much
like meeting somebody in being hi how
are you what is your name and where are
you from that's pretty much what a st.
mark is designed to do and it is done
generally by territorial animals non
territorial animals don't really send
mark they just urinate and defecate and
so if you do you want to kind of draw
the distinguish between urination and
and scent marking the st. marking is the
act of deliberately spraying strategic
points within an area that demarcates a
territory whereas urination is just
going to the toilet whenever and
wherever and so husana most of the time
will be just urinating because he's not
a territorial male just yet whereas ting
gana is strategically sent marking in
order to lay down a boundary in order to
to establish a territory and deter
others from coming in by using a
chemical scent body odor like I say is
just you know that's bacteria
essentially that is causing that smell
to come on and end and and only I heard
Steve say that lions and leopards both
stink and I think it's a very big
disservice to sour spotted cats I didn't
think lipid stink at all I mean I've
spent my fair share of time with a
leopard and yes what comes out of them
in the form of their excrement does
stink but a leopard itself very very
very very seldom does it smell I adore
sauna this morning literally under my
nose and there was absolutely no scent
coming off this cat whatsoever there was
no smell that I could pick up that would
say leopard or any other thing
so they to me don't have a scent Lions
also do not have a scent unless they
have been eating a carcass which is
generally means they have
client in and they've got that smell of
blood and rotten flesh all over them and
then they can absolutely really kind of
be pungent as they go past so they can
smell but generally only around food if
they haven't been eating they don't
smell at all in my opinion as well I
don't think that they are smelly cats
cats generally in Knotts many they're
normally pretty well groomed funny
enough talking about smell um Conrad he
was sleeping the other nights and he
said to me he woke up out of his sleep
because a hyena had walked past and the
smell of rotten flesh was so strong that
it actually worked him up out of his
sleep now Conrad is a good sleeper so
you can imagine how stinky that hyena
must have been and makes you wonder what
carcass it had been eating because
that's generally the case when they've
been eating a week-old elephant or hippo
that they've been climbing around in to
smell that bad but Conrad was horrified
by the scent and was very unimpressed by
his rude awakening as the improperly
hyena walked past his open window and
smelt it now I think it was Matt Miller
I think was the name do these animals
are there able to determine bad versus
good scent so something that smells good
Miller is that right faith bad versus
good smells for sure I mean they will be
able to you see sometimes they smell
something in their ear back straightaway
and that's generally something that they
don't like yes these probably smells
that smell bad to them not necessarily
what smells bad to us so the right smell
of a rotten carcass doesn't really smell
bad for predator they smell that and
they see food you know it's like
smelling your favorite food as you drive
down the road and the restaurant that
cooks your favorite food that makes you
just want to go and eat like a bakery
bakeries are the worst for making you
hungry use drive pass freshly baked
bread and it's like that kind of hunger
just takes over so they're smalls versus
ours would be very very different but I
I'm pretty sure that they can determine
something that smells good versus I mean
that smells
bad or something that potentially is a
threat like lion and the leopard or
whatever it may be so they far more
sophisticated their sensory organs and
what most of ours on if we can determine
that's yes we've got a bigger brain
that's able to compute these things but
I'm pretty sure that they're able to
work out their environment through smell
sound and hearing just as well as what
we are able to do maybe not like I say
as big a range of kind of smells in
terms of how we defined good and bad and
okay I think phase is just good or bad
depending on the threat level or food
opportunity really I don't think there's
much more to it than that but as you can
see lisanna is just sitting in for so
confidently and just listening almost
he's kind of moving around there's the
full moon that Lauren was talking about
the strawberry moon that's this month's
full moon that's the name of this
month's full moon and that's probably
due to the fact that strawberries will
be harvested in the northern hemisphere
around this time Thomas time for
Wimbledon which means strawberry time
and strawberries and cream which is
James's favorite time of the year and he
does like to indulge as well as David in
a strawberry and cream dessert from time
to time but it's been an absolutely
wonderful afternoon hopefully you've
enjoyed yourselves with us and hopefully
you think to carry on watching because
we are going to be coming back live in
about half an hour's time for our TV
show and hopefully Hasan is going to put
on a show I mean well I think you will
and then I also think that Steven Lauren
I'm gonna come good with something very
epic because of the work that they've
put into but from all of us been an
absolute pleasure and we'll see you all
tomorrow morning bye for now